[Music]
so while everybody's all in this crazy
flurry over what cat William said about
all these different comedians uh a lot
of people don't realize how uh far back
the Kevin har and Cat William stuff goes
like their beef yeah yeah they've had be
for a long time like Cat Williams really
like really probably believes that Kevin
hars an industry plant wow really yeah
what does that even mean by the way I
hear people say this person's industry
plan what does that mean I don't really
your your your whole career has been
like laid out for you by a whole team
and then they constructed your rise to
fame done a film with old Kev I didn't
see any evidence of
that is there someone we could think of
that is like typically like guess known
as like an industry
plant it's hard to prove I think it's
hard to prove people say that about
about Taylor Swift for a while and then
she just completely proved her talent to
everybody and just smashed all the
haters yeah he's a Swifty though for for
Kevin Hart particularly there's like a
thing a lot of people really believe
this too that like when Cat Williams
started to uh kind of when he was like
on the come up and different producers
were asking him to do different things
the more he would say no to things the
more they were like oh we're going to
need a replacement for the opportunities
that were meant to go to cat because
he's not willing to do certain things
and so people believe Kevin Hart is that
guy because Kevin Hart kind of did not
come up in the scene of doing standup
shows selling them out and then becoming
a movie star got he kind of just like
like people were like I saw him in Scary
Movie 3 then all of a sudden next year
he was in everything
real squard all I feel like I I used to
watch him on the early days of like
Comedy Central when he would first come
on like when he was like a early stand
up he was on wild and out a lot in the
early even before wild and out before he
was popping on any movies I remember
seeing him do like Comedy Central
presents like Kevin Hart you're like who
the [__] is this dude you know like back
in those days I think by then I think
that's the thing it's like already PR
high and uh just like what cat was
saying he's like I there's no photos or
videos of people standing in line that a
sold out Kevin Hart standup like night
my argument to that would be so I don't
know what's like what's right or wrong
or facts or whatever but my argument to
that is if comedians don't have the
talent they can't hold the room yeah so
if someone like if you've never done a
1,000 person show 4,000 5,000 then you
give them Madison Square Garden they're
not going to be able to rock that and
sold out show for every single weekend
and I've been to a couple Kevin Hart
shows and he [__] rushes it like
rockar he in arguably there's no way if
he doesn't have the chops to do movies
and then randomly do stand up but his
entire set is industry scripted there's
that whole thing about do you guys know
the whole thing behind like when Dave
Chappelle was explaining that uh
producers were asking him to put a dress
on for a scene and he was like that's
like a known thing for a lot of
that's like like a lot of people view
that as like almost like yes yes I'll do
it
yes and then um there's a there's a part
where Kevin Hart's being interviewed
about the Dave Chappelle interview and
Kevin Hart's like yeah uh I don't think
you would you should try to uh he's like
saying you shouldn't sacrifice your own
um whatever your morals are whatever but
he's not explicitly saying he wouldn't
do it it's more like he's explaining why
Dave Chappelle wouldn't do it but he
didn't actually explicitly say I would
never do that so by the time Kevin Hart
was on SNL and they he wore a dress in a
wig a lot of people were like they had
that like freaking you
know yeah you know what I mean like he's
doing the thinga I can't whistle and
then so they were like oh look he's
doing the thing that he said he wouldn't
do but like he didn't really say that so
that's what Cat Williams is kind of
talking about in his interview that like
oh look like uh Kevin har said he would
never wear the dress until he wore it
look at him now yeah and look at him now
C's kind of a little hater though I I
think he's he sounds like chip on his
shoulder being a little jealous of of
kev's success but then the funny thing
is is like he he also has his own amount
of success like who was the biggest dude
ever he's like telling he was saying
like oh yeah I'm not making $85 million
last year but I'm making a million like
I don't I'm not in a position to you
know but I dude I remember Cat Williams
was so hot at one point and then he got
beat up by the seventh grader yeah
that's when I was like you guys remember
that I think we covered that [__] here I
don't even remember that that that
seventh grader look bro I get it seventh
grader
move but that [__] choked out
Cat Williams and like they were the
video is crazy they're in like a a
[__] but right before that cat was
sick dude he's still funny as [__] I
still love no he but he did get his by
seven that's come back from from anybody
I saw that 2our plus podcast you know
that everyone's talking about um what I
took from all of this is someone who's
able to finally like tell you the behind
the scenes that we were all kind of like
questioning like what's going on here
with this and that and then and he's
always been real about it but also I see
him as a purist and some people that
only care about their skill they don't
really like people that take other
Pathways to get famous or not cuz the
thing that he emphasized is like you're
not a standup you're a host so like if
you're not a legitimate standup why are
you going out there speaking for the
rest of us and I think that was his
biggest correl with most people is like
St Harvey right Steve Harvey he's a host
he says that these people I did not see
you do the circuits I did not see you do
all these things that we did so I'm like
okay in that case it makes sense it's
like hey this guy's a legitimate sword
maker he spent his life he went through
this or like a black belt in Jiu-Jitsu
right you have all these other guys
claiming I'm a black belt too but then
it's like well what school did you go to
right so I think when I heard his talk
it sounded like that it was like this is
the art of standup
and then he's kind of a purist and all
these other guys they're it's a facade
have you guys seen the standup bits that
he was talking about cat was talking
about yeah I se with uh I think what
Steve Harvey I saw that one that was
crazy really close the Cedric the
Entertainer one Steve Harvey one it's
word for word broo what are you talking
about they stole from Mark Curry he was
a comedian that Cat Williams was talking
about and they did side by side I think
with Mark Curry and uh Cedric the
Entertainer well they joke stole a lot
of Cat Williams material and then they G
him like that never happened a lot of
the top guys that made it to like
mainstream success they stole from the
guys that like are actual Comics
Grinders yeah the actual like Grinders
maybe a headliner or something they were
taking their closers yeah yeah where
it's like really off set up and punch
and there's a guy that edited too like
you can see the actual video that
they're referencing you can see the
original video of Cat Williams and other
comics and you can see Cedric the
Entertainer you can see Steve Harvey
especially yeah dude dude even the
physical part of it Williams would do
that [__] so here's like just focusing
on the Kevin Hart thing is what I wanted
to do because that his one of his
responses just came out Kevin Heart
yeah perspective on that and your
response that situation uh I said it and
this this sums it up well like you don't
you don't entertain the circus you watch
it right and when a lion comes out and
rides the bike you don't think about it
too hard you just go okay that's crazy a
lion riding a bike and then you go home
and enjoy the rest of your day uh I
don't feed into the stuff at all at the
end of the day it's it's all
entertainment to a certain degree so you
just hope that people can be smart
enough and have a tremendous amount of
logic to just go and possibly do
research or fact check and if they do
then great if they don't then to those
to that as well uh I just don't have the
time for it there's too much going on so
to your point while parting and
promoting a movie uh I think the biggest
priority for me is getting my fan base
to understand how excited I am about the
work that I put into this because that's
where my focus is is getting eyeballs to
the thing that took me about four months
to shoot R even longer good he's a
professional he's an industry plan yeah
dude he's Hollywood how say he knows how
to speak this in the past he's even
cooler in person
he's in the past he's had other
interviews where he really like goes in
on Cat and like talks about him now it's
interesting cuz he's he's really like
refusing toage even acknowledge it yeah
yeah yeah but he's had some pretty long
like dises back this time it's it's just
not that so it's kind of it could be
he's like just Rising above it all and
he's like building companies and movies
and he's like I don't even want to deal
with this [__] his Focus different
he was asked about about what cat
thought of him he said a bunch of [__]
about how like yeah cat was given these
opportunities and and he he was the one
that blew it because of his addiction or
because of his thing and then cat was
like I'm not not even on drugs there's
no record of me like they it would be
pretty bad you know but I feel like
Kevin Hart nowadays like yeah he's
always going to be a standup in our eyes
but I feel like now he's like
transcended that like he's just like I
look at him like the Rock and [__] you
he's a household character and
everybody's yeah Jim Carrey too like he
he basically gave up stand up and just
did movies after yeah yeah he be kind of
like the Kevin Hart path and now a
painter you know what's crazy we
actually do have a a connection with
Kevin Hart you know Walter Hong yeah so
Walter used to be in the same sketch
group as Kevin Hart back in the day and
then Walter uh he used to host chocolate
Sundays at La Factory oh yeah and he was
like the he just like he was like the
talent that Kevin had was so undeniable
cuz it would have like B or C great
scripts and when Kevin took a hold of
the script it just became infinitely
more funny oh wow so just even from like
15 20 years ago he was like he just knew
like this guy is isn't going to stay in
my sketch group for long and he's just
going to transcend like whatever of
course Walter is going to say that he's
an industry plant too that's true Walter
is the biggest be the first to tell you
you guys have two connections to
kevar yeah yeah how could you [__]
say that in front also it's like one of
those things that like if Kevin Hart's
really making like 85 mil or some [__] a
year and like catne is making like a m
of course he's going to be sitting there
like yeah I don't got time for this
watch my movie you know what I mean use
the attention true turn it into my movie
I do like the interview cuz he does
share a lot of like behind the scenes
stuff and what I like about it is it
does feel like during his whole career
Cat Williams like whether or not like
whose morals are what Cat Williams stuck
to his guns of what of how he wanted to
in his own words like protect his booty
ho while making it right yeah which I
think is cool where I think a lot of
times you it's it's easy to get tempted
and go oh maybe I'll do this and then
eventually you find yourself in a
certain place but then you're like [__]
I had so much much of my own self
sacrifice I had to do to get there Kevin
Hart doesn't exactly seem like a
miserable
guy and he did explain about the dress
he was like I thought it was funny he's
like I read the script I thought it was
funny like that can also be true you
know as long as he wants to do the bit
right that's all that really matters and
as much as people like there's a large
uh group of people that are perpetuating
this idea that like that putting black
comedians or black actors in address is
a way to like racially it's like some
kind of attack or some kind of like
imasc
yeah like but it's like there is a even
bigger list of just everybody does that
[__] for comedy it's just kind of
funnier to be a girl fire Eddie Murphy
like has houses because he did that [__]
to Wang
Fu whole thing is about that so I mean
it's not isolated it is a comedy thing
as well maybe they're both true who
knows but hey you got Kevin Hart's
number on your phone you know like U
should call I on
WhatsApp see if he's online right now
please yeah yeah I think he is I think
he's
h